quand la guerre a commencé
ils m'ont protégé
ils ont pris soin de moi encore mieux
que tu es humain
c'est juste un programme
nucléaire a été lancée sur le Los
Angeles par l'intelligence artificielle
conçu pour le protéger
il s'agit d'un combat pour notre propre
survie
c'est argenté l'or la victoire est à
portée de main
mais les y a développe une arme
surpuissante exécutez-la
[Musique]
avez-vous localisé l'arbre c'est une
gamine
[Musique]
on est pareil on peut pas aller au
paradis parce que toi tu es pas gentil
et moi je suis pas une personne
tu as une idée de ce que c'est
pour l'instant on dirait une gamine mais
elle grandit
ce qui auront l'enfant remporteront la
guerre
t'es dans quel camps
soient enfin libres
je crois pas qu'on est en magasin tu as
mis les glaces